good morning Hank its January 2nd 2012
five years ago today I uploaded my first
vlog brothers video in honor of that
anniversary here's a terrible jump cut
so slow Hank I hate chains but when I
look back at the last five years I can't
help but think that things have changed
for the better for instance I used to
not have a kid who could say awesome yes
Hank five years ago today I would never
have guessed that there would be a
nerdfighter or a project for awesome or
in your pants jokes or an evil baby
orphanage there still isn't an evil baby
orphanage but there should be which just
maybe time machine Hank speaking of
which I found the perfect location for
the evil baby orphanage did you know
that the philippine island of luzon
contains a lake which contains an island
which contains a lake which contains an
island that's the island on which we
should put the evil baby orphanage you
know once we get the time machine and
collect all the evil babies etc right
Hank so I had changed but it being a new
year it's time for some changes change
number one in the past we have referred
to 2007 2008 2009 hey I would like to
propose that we switch it to 2012 why is
this important it's not however it's a
way to save some syllables and also we
didn't let go through all the nineteen
hundreds calling everything 19 186 at
some point you make the change and now
is the time
2011 sounded weird 2010 sounded weird
2012 sounds great change number two for
the past several months your pants has
been down due to Russian hackers but
your pants is coming back this week
huzzah change number three I think we
should say huzzah more often not so much
that it's a thing but enough that it's
like a secret thing change number 4 -
vlogbrothers videos per week in 2012 ah
don't throw things at me I'm sorry Hank
every week you'll see me on Tuesday and
I'll see you on Friday this is primarily
because I'm still sick and one of the
things my doctor's want me to do is
scale back on work a little bit so I'm
going to try to honor their wishes I
think the other reason is that in trying
to make three videos a week the thing
that we've let slide is all the project
based nerdfighter increasing awesome and
decreasing world sucks stuff that we
love so much and remember in 2012 there
will be more vlogbrothers content than
ever because we're going to teach you
biology and world history on our Channel
crash course link in the doobly-doo and
today
a hank is launching scishow his show
where he talks to you about science and
he's very funny Willie I've tried to
make a video also because the first
episodes of scishow were filmed in
November Hank has that hideous goatee
that so many of you inexplicably like
sadly Hank you failed to film an episode
with that epic policeman mustache jerk
butters let us know in comments what you
would like to see more of from us in
2012 and also what you would like to see
more of in the community so I know
change starts up at nerdfighters I hope
you understand hank dftba I will see you
on Friday
I'm gonna go play with that guy sounds
like I was talking about God but I was
talking about Henry he's upstairs